everyone in this sleepy Mountain Town
had heard stories about the abandoned
mall and the malevolent creature that
lurked in the wreckage there there had
been enough missing persons cases lost
children teenagers sneaking out to
explore and never returning home Urban
explorers who stumbled out of the
darkness disheveled and traumatized with
an eyewitness account no one wanted to
believe there wasn't anyone left in the
surrounding area willing to set foot in
that cursed place but that didn't stop
opportunistic out-of-towners from paying
the occasional visit especially if they
felt like there was money to be made in
those crumbling corporate walls Grant
and Jason the hosts of up-and-coming
investigative reality show ghostly
happenings were two such visitors when
they heard the rumors about an abandoned
Mall haunted by some sort of dark
presence blamed for The Disappearance of
local children they packed up their van
picked up their underpaid cameraman
Derek and headed straight for the
infamous building are you sure we're
allowed to be here Derek asks shakely as
he began filming nope Grant answered
cheerfully that's part of the fun Jason
laughed look man this place has been
left to rot by the city no one cares if
we're shooting some footage besides
worrying less about the cops and more
about the ghosts of them all Grand grin
not funny Derek crumbled come on serious
faces were rolling Jason nudged his
co-host and the two snapped into their
on-camera personalities once a bustling
Center of suburban American life this
shopping mall has transformed into a den
of Terror Grant's voice dropped into a
lower register his expression intense
local swap stories of something inhuman
that calls this place home something
that doesn't take kindly to trespassers
Jason added a ghost a demon just an
urban legend that's what we're here to
find out Grant pulled out an EMF reader
which began beeping as he turned it on
ah there seems to be a lot of activity
in here already I'm picking up something
don't know if you folks at home can see
this put the meters going crazy Jason
exclaimed it was a fake meter of course
one that they rigged up to beep and
react when Grant pressed certain hidden
buttons but the audience didn't need to
know that they were tuning in for story
for spectacle no not for the truth if
they wanted that they could flip over to
the nature Channel and watch some lions
chasing a gazelle on this show they were
chasing pure entertainment they
continued deeper into the building
taking in the massive echoey space the
dusty storefronts the beams of rotten
Woods strewn across the ground the rats
that skittered across the floor it was
the perfect creepy atmosphere maybe a
little too perfect a little too creepy
what was that Derek practically jumped
out of his skin spinning around to look
at something behind him hey stay on us
Grant snapped I saw something moving
back there Derek insisted it was a rat
Jason rolled his eyes there are tons of
them in here Derek shook his head no it
wasn't a rat it was way too big okay a
raccoon man come on get it together
we've been in way worse locations than
this remember that old tuberculosis
Hospital Grant shuttered God man that
was scary this is nothing well not
nothing Jason elbowed his partner I I
did a good job scouting this place right
grant was about to answer when his foot
bumped something on the ground he looked
down and saw a Polaroid camera next to a
long empty water bottle and a small
backpack oh man get a shot of this Derek
obliged while Jason took a closer look
this must have belonged to one of the
Urban Explorer types who came in here he
unzipped the backpack rummaging around
hey look photos tons of them he dumped
the pictures out onto the ground think
he got some Spirit photography done
before he bit the dust I might as well
see Grant joined Jason on the ground
sifting through the photos as Derek
watched anxiously barring boring dear
dog Sunset oh wait a minute he stopped
holding up one specific Polaroid this is
the money shot right here Derek zoom in
on this all three men looked at the
picture illuminated by the camera's
light it showed a tall long limbed pale
creature vaguely humanoid in shape but
at the same time distinctly not quite
human its mouth was stretched wide in a
wordless screech its eyes bloodshot and
wild its long tapered fingers were
reaching towards the camera damn that's
spooky Jason laughed a bit of
nervousness creeping into his voice how
do you think he set this up Grant asked
what if it's real Derek swallowed the
lump in his throat don't be an idiot
Grand scoff but then from the outside
not 100 feet away they heard a scream
ears splittingly loud filled with rage
pain and animalistic Instinct it was
like nothing any of them had ever heard
before the scream was followed by the
sound of splitting wood branches
crashing to the ground and horrifyingly
the sound of something breaking down a
nearby wall what did you do Jason backed
away from the sound me you open the
backpack Grant shot back guys I think we
need to get out of here Derek watched in
white-eyed Terror as two pale hands
ripped a hole in the wall in front of
them making an opening for that pale
hairless head from the photograph to
poke through all three men prepared to
make a break for it and run for their
lives but as soon as the creature saw
them it was already too late with
another scream scp-096 sprinted toward
them grabbing each man and throwing them
to the ground the camera shattered into
pieces from the impact and Derek skidded
painfully across the ground as he rolled
onto his side to try and push back up to
his feet he caught a glimpse of the
monster opening its mouth impossibly
wide and descending on his bosses he
really didn't want to focus on what
happened next but suffice to say there
was nothing of them left afterwards
Derek tried his best to escape but he
was no match for the brute strength and
speed of scp-096 from the moment he saw
its face his fate was sealed there was
no Escape soon the beeping EMF meter the
scattered photographs and the broken
pieces of the camera were the only thing
left of the crew from ghostly happenings
their devoted fans would never get
another episode but at least one being
in the abandoned Mall could rest easy
now
scp-096 was safe again no one was living
who had seen its face it slowly crawled
back to the hole it had made in the wall
ready to return to the forest and climb
back up the mountain there could curl up
beneath a tree and stay there for as
long as it wanted but as scp-096 reached
the hole in the wall where it had once
been able to see night sky stars and the
trees in the distance there was only
Blackness it was as if something dark
was stretching over the opening blocking
the outside world from view 096 reached
out a hand to push the blockage out of
the way but whatever it was slithered
away from the touch faster than the pale
hand could move the wriggling darkness
crept back into the building weaving in
and out of the shadows as scp-096
watched it curiously whatever it was it
hadn't looked at the creature's face yet
it wasn't sure if this thing even had
eyes but then stretching out of the
darkness and an interview was a garish
face with wide white eyes with massive
pupils a round nose and a wide wide
mouth stretched into a toothy Grimace
that might have once looked like a smile
this was the creature that had made the
mall its home the apex predator of this
biosphere and it was staring directly at
a
scp-096's face it's face with the shriek
096 flew into a Primal Rage clawing at
the cat-like creature but before 096
could reach it the thing was gone where
was it where did it go 096 roared
tearing at the floor ripping up the tile
and gouging long deep scratches in the
concrete beneath a sound in the distance
Drew 096's attention and it bolted in
the direction of the noise swinging at
any obstacle in its path as it went it
ripped down a banner advertising free
frozen yogurt samples crushed an empty
cell phone kiosk and threw a gumball
machine to the floor with a crash it
would rip the entire Mall apart if it
had to if that was what it took to
destroy the being that I'd caught a
glimpse of its face and disappeared then
096 could see it that face that
wide-eyed grinning face it sprinted
toward the face as fast as it could the
cartoon cat was looking at 096 not from
a place in the room but from behind the
screen of a television in the electronic
store window somehow defying the laws of
physics and reality it had made its way
into the TV 096 didn't pause to ponder
the logic of this there was no room for
critical thought there was only the need
to shred to consume to destroy it burst
through the window sending shards of
glass in every direction and reared back
to attack the screen it was so focused
on its singular task that it didn't
notice the long black arms snaking
across the floor winding around its feet
all of a sudden 096 lost its balance as
its legs were pulled right out from
under it those stretchy arms dragging it
into the TV screen itself when 096
regained Consciousness it was in a place
it did not recognize gone was the inside
of them all or the familiar forest and
mountains outside instead scp-096 was in
some sort of hand-drawn World a massive
house with a hallway that seemed to go
on forever lined with infinite doors
leading to who knew where the floor
tipped and tilted at odd angles and the
geometry made no three-dimensional sense
it was dizzying and deeply off-putting
scp-096 had no frame of reference to
compare it to but a human witness might
have noticed that this place looked like
something out of an old cartoon from the
days of Steamboat Willie and the like
scp-096 did not think such a thing it
only knew that it was in an unfamiliar
Place one that fell threatening though
there were no visible threats and it
knew that it still hadn't gotten its
hands on the creature that had seen its
face all along the walls between each
door there were clocks in the shape of
that horrible cat eyes ticking back and
forth with each second wide smile
mocking scp-096 as if to say try and
find me
scp-096 would not be discouraged there
was no room in its mind for that sort of
thing there was only the singular goal
of finding the cartoon cat and tearing
it limb from rubber hose limb
psychological warfare would have no
effect still cartoon cat would give it
his best shot this was his world and he
could do whatever he wanted here cartoon
cat poked his head out through a random
doorway waving to 096 with one of his
puffy white gloved hands as 096 wailed
and began to give Chase cartoon cats
slammed the door shut only to open
another door down the hall and poke his
head head out of that one he did the
same trick over and over jerking scp-096
around from end to end of the ever
expanding animated hallway after some
time passed however it appeared as cp096
was not going to get tired and was not
going to give up hope of catching its
prey it was time to end this cartoon cat
wrapped one long arm around
scp-096's neck restraining it against
the wall and began to squeeze Tighter
and Tighter but nothing happened
scp-096 did not collapse did not react
at all except to tear out the arm around
its neck until it broke free then it
returned to the Relentless Pursuit
tearing door frames apart pulling up
floorboards punching through walls every
time it dealt damage to the environment
the space filled itself back in an
unseen pen scribbling in the gaps in the
floorboards sealing up the holes and the
walls two powerful beings going back and
forth locked in a seemingly equal
matched battle cartoon cat tried to
destroy scp-096 in a myriad of ways he
tried to rip the Beast apart to snap its
neck to do any manner of unspeakable
violent acts that had done before with
great sadistic Glee but this pale
Abomination would not fold would not
break this wasn't going to be any fun if
there was no ending and if 096 kept
destroying one of cartoon cat's favorite
pocket worlds that was quite enough
cartoon cat grabbed hold of 096's arms
and legs the creature thrashing
viciously as he did so and threw it into
the blank space just beyond the
Illustrated world back in the mall
scp-096 crashed back to Earth was about
to resume its search for cartoon cat
when suddenly a bright light illuminated
its face a police officer stood a few
feet away holding a flashlight excuse me
you can't be in here your trespassing
the officer started to warn but his
words were interrupted when 096 began to
scream soon he would be screaming too
now go and check out scp-049 cures
scp-096 of the pestilence and scp-096
versus siren head for more Shy Guy
crossovers you won't be afraid to look
at